welcome back
today's lecture is about unsupervised
learning so let's recall what we meant
by supervised learning and contrast it
with unsupervised learning so supervised
learning the word supervised remember
refers to the fact that there's a target
a a label that we're trying to predict
from training data so we have features
and
we're trying to predict the label and
the label supervises the the learning
for example like if you're in
kindergarten you can think of a
kindergarten teacher who shows a child
in the class a bunch of examples of say
johnny here's here's here's here's a
five examples of a house in in lego
blocks here's five examples of a car
right and he tells johnny that these are
houses and these are cars
so he's supervising the learning and
uh the child then looks at his and
figures out which features of the house
make a characteristic of a house and
which features of the car make a
characteristic of a car so that's
supervised learning um in contrast
unsupervised learning there's no labels
so this kindergarten teacher would tell
we'll just show johnny here's 10 10
things
and doesn't tell johnny that these five
are cars and these five are houses
and the child then
looks at the objects and tries to figure
out some patterns he says if he may
realize ah these five look similar
i don't know if they're called but they
look similar so maybe i should group
them together these other five look
similar to each other and i'll put them
in the group so yes so this means we
have a
with supervisor we have a y
and with unsupervised we don't
exactly right right so in both we have
features but as trevor said in
supervisor we have a y that's we're
given in the training data that's a true
label
and unsupervised learning is harder in a
sense because we don't have
the actual labels
so let's move to slide one um most of
the course as as we've seen focuses on
the first
exercise supervised learning where we
have labels
but today we're going to talk about the
setting where we um where we don't have
labels unsupervised learning all we
observe with the features which as
before we'll call x1 through xp
and um
we want to know how
um
the features that how the features
relate to each other
so
in particular what are the goals of
unsupervised learning well then first of
all they're not as clear as they are for
supervised learning where the object is
to predict y from x
now we don't have a y so
the objective is a little more fuzzy
for example
we might want to
discover subgroups among the
observations like in my kindergarten
example right the child may try to try
to
discover subgroups among the objects
he's seen
um
we might want to know is there a good
way to to view the data to to find the
important features or the features that
have the most variation over the
different objects
so we're going to discuss there are lots
of methods for unsupervised learning but
in this
short lecture we're just going to talk
about two of the most important ones
first is principal components analysis
which is a tool
reviewing data or for pre-processing
uh the features for use later in
supervised learning this and the second
is is clustering which is a group of
methods for for a class of methods for
grouping the objects into different
subgroups okay so we'll talk
um about those two methods today
but let's say a little more in general
about the about the the challenge of
unsupervised learning as i mentioned
it's
uh
there's it's a little more fuzzy because
there's no simple objective like
prediction right there's no y available
so we don't we're not just we're not
predicting
uh the objective as we saw in the
previous slide is a little more um
a little more fuzzy
but
nonetheless unsupervised learning is is
actually of growing importance and
there's a number of reasons for that
um
well first of all let's see some
examples samples actually see at the end
of the lecture an example example is um
we have um
breast cancer patients from whom we
measure gene expression using gene chips
and we want to we want to group those
patients into subgroups of of breast
cancer it turns out these subgroups are
actually quite different in terms of
their characteristics biologically and
their survival as patients
another example uh which is in in
marketing is to find if we have if we
have uh we have shoppers
and
we can we can record their uh their
browsing and purchase histories we can
group or segment the shoppers into
different groups
and then maybe they'll be targeted with
different kinds of advertising because
their behaviors are different
another example which is quite popular
is
is uh to group
movies
by the by their the ratings assigned by
movie viewers
like a thriller romance etc
okay
and the other the other thing that makes
uh unsupervisory more and more important
is that it's there's a lot more
unlabeled data available and that's
because the the the
um
in order to get labels for data it can
be costly or time consuming right for
example there's tons of images on the
web
i mean everybody's loading up images and
google and other places and mostly they
are unlabeled you don't know
no one's told us exactly what's in the
picture but we have the pictures right
and the point is that that kind of
information can be uh collected by
machine the the features the images but
the actual labeling it often requires
human intervention right and that's
going to be more costly and
time-consuming
an example of that is our um
movie reviews on the web a lot of people
they they try to predict that well they
try to uh correlate movie reviews with
movie quality and group movies one
problem there is that if you have a
movie review written by a human being
right it's hard to tell
by machine whether or not that that is
actually favorable or not right if the
movie review could have some sarcasm in
it right and for a human reading the
paragraph it's pretty easy to say oh
that person doesn't like the movie or
does like the movie but for a computer
it's not so easy so uh so um that's
example where we're finding the actual
label can be quite difficult and time
consuming
okay so let's start with the first main
method for
unsupervised learning principle
components analysis this goes back
probably to the 1930s in statistics when
it was first invented
so pca produces a loaded a
low dimensional representation of a data
set and it finds a sequence of linear
combinations of the variables or
features that have maximal variance
and the same time they're uncorrelated
so we're going to see there's a first
principle component which has the
highest variance across the data it's a
linear combination of the features
and then a second component which is is
uncorrelated with the first which has
the highest variance under that
constraint etc just imagine you have
tons of variables and many of them are
correlated
that can be quite an unmanageable set
what principal components tries to do is
pair the set down into
some important
variables that summarize all the
information in the data and that's these
principal components right and that can
be very useful just as just as a way of
viewing the data if you have a high
dimensional data set you just want to
have a look at
what's really happening here what's
important the principal component view
is one of the most important ways of
of displaying the data and second of all
you have a lot of features you want to
use for supervised learning the
principle component summary of those
variables can be
a good way to use a good set of new
variables to use for supervised learning
principle components and and the
techniques related to it is one of the
most widely used tools in in statistics
and data analysis
okay so let's talk about let's actually
define principal components so we have a
set of variables x1 through xp
um and the principal component z first
principal component z1 is a linear
combination of those variables
and it's a linear combination to find
our highest variance across the data set
now of course we
we're going to choose weights well it's
defined by a set of weights v1 through
vp
but
if i was allowed to make those weights
as big as i wanted i could make the
variance of z1 as because i wanted so we
need some constraint on the on the fees
um and the natural constraint is that
they're normalized so the sum of their
squares is one okay
that now makes the problem uh a sensible
one to
to choose a set of weights that has the
highest variance
those weights are called loadings
um in the
in
some areas of statistics and other other
social sciences
um so the fee 1 fee 1 1 through p1p are
the loadings of the first principal
component
the the the principal point that the
voting vector is the set of those p
numbers
if you didn't constrain them of course
you could just make them much bigger and
that would just make the variance higher
so you need to tie them down exactly
so here's an example before we talk
about how to actually compute the
components let's just see what the the
result of what
the first two components for the
for this data which is um
ad spending versus population so here's
the the red points are my
are the data points i plotted them
against these two variables so p is just
two in this example
the first principal component is given
by
the the projection of the data onto this
line so
this this direction has the highest
variance
among all combinations of the features
in this data
correspondingly this has the lowest
variance right oh well sorry well yeah
that's true this has the lowest variance
so here's only two components so i've
got the highest variance the first
principal component
the second component is also
well it's it's got it's got the the
highest variance
uh with the constraint to be
uncorrelated with the first component
which means it has to have right angles
with the first component there it is if
you only have two variables you can only
get out two components exactly but just
for illustration we show you two
variables
okay so how do we actually compute the
components well now suppose we have our
data which are features n by p at the x
matrix
and now since we're only interested in
the variance
we
um
we can
we can center the variables to have mean
zero right we don't care about the mean
we're just worrying about the variance
so in other words in particular and
specifically we make the column means of
x0
and then we want to find the
combination of the variables
that has the highest variance remember
highest variance under the constraint
that these loadings have sum of squares
1.
now since since the the data have been
arranged to have mean zero in the first
step that means the z's have mean zero
and hence the variance is just the sum
of the square of the z's is the sum of
their squares
okay so
to continue the computation
we have the z's which we've defined to
be this the sum of the
the loadings times the features
and so now the problem now we can
replace the z's by their expression from
the previous slide and we want to find
the highest variance now which is this
expression subject to the fact that the
loadings have to be normalized right
so this is not now just a computational
problem where the unknowns are these
fees and the optimization can be done
but by the singular value decomposition
which is a standard technique in
numerical analysis which you won't cover
but if you want to read about it
yourself it's uh
very interesting and very important in a
lot of areas of statistics
and it's covered for example in our book
uh elements of statistical learning
so when we solve this problem and we got
the the the
best loadings
the resulting
z values
are the first principal component which
we'll write as z11 to zn1
so it's like we've created a new
variable now we had
we had our original p variables now
we've we've created a new variable which
is the c1 which has n values just like
each of our original variables
exactly so um
that now we can think of that
geometrically we'll go back to the
picture in a moment so
the loading vector is a direction on
which we uh a direction of the features
that uh has
if we project down that direction has
the highest variance
and the the the values of the projected
the data are called are the principal
component scores so let's go back to our
the picture of the two-dimensional one
okay
so i said this was the first principle
component
that means the
the loading vector is the vector that
points in the direction
from the middle to the northeast right
so here might be something like
maybe 1 1 or
roughly okay
so that's the combination of the
features that we compute using principal
components the actual computed values
are the projections onto this line so
it's we could start say the origin could
be here we could we could just measure
which point we take its projection onto
this line
we measure how far does it away from
say this or the origin here
okay so the z's for these guys would be
positive and the use for these guys
would be negative so we replaced each
point by basically how far along this
line is it
and that's the first principal component